Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit. Dem Podcast, der eine neue Heimat gefunden hat, hier in der Metaebene. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer längeren Pause führen wir hier das Programm wieder weiter in Eigenregie. Und ja, die Pause war so ein bisschen erforderlich, um ein bisschen zu sortieren, wie die Reise so weitergehen soll. Aber im Prinzip wird sich hier am Programm nicht ändern. Wir werden nach wie vor auf die Raumfahrt blicken, auf alle interessanten Technologien, Entwicklungen und wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse, die sich hier so herausziehen lassen. Jetzt ist es 2015 und ich denke, es ist sehr angemessen, auf ein Projekt zu schauen, was Ende 2014 für großes Aufsehen gesorgt hat. Konkret handelt es sich um die Mission Philae, Teil der Rosetta-Mission, die hier auch schon mal ein Thema war. Vor ein paar Jahren schon mit Gerhard Schwem zusammen haben wir hier über Giotto und Rosetta gesprochen, was schon ein sehr interessanter Ausflug war, zu der gesamten Fragestellung, wie besucht man eigentlich Kometen und wie schaut man auf diese Weltraumobjekte genauer. Da hat Giotto schon den Weg bereitet und Rosetta war dann die Mission, die zu dem Zeitpunkt vielversprechend unterwegs war. Das Gespräch fand statt, kurz bevor Rosetta in den Dauerschlaf ging, dann halb abgeschaltet durch den Weltraum zog und irgendwann dann wieder aufgeweckt wurde, um das eigentliche Ziel zu erreichen, nämlich 67P, den Kometen, Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko, einen Zungenbrecher. Gut, dass man auch 67P sagen kann. Ja, und um jetzt viele genauer zu besprechen, begrüße ich Stefan Ulametz. Schönen guten Tag. Hallo. Ja, du bist der offizielle Bezeichnung?
Ja, das ist der Projektleiter, Project Manager vom Rosetta Lander, von Philae.
Genau. Wir sind jetzt hier auch gerade in Köln, auf dem DLR-Standort. Und ja, wo fangen wir an? Also Rosetta, die Raumsonde, hat einen weiten Weg genommen und ist dann letzten Endes eingeschert auf den richtigen Kurs, hat sich an den Kometen rangehängt und dort kam es dann auch zum Einfangen quasi des Kometen, also er hat sich nicht aufhalten lassen, aber Rosetta war dann auf jeden Fall auf der richtigen Spur, hat dann ein Orbit eingenommen um diesen Kometen herum und am Ende wurde Philae auf diesen Kometen abgesetzt. Das ist so ein bisschen die Vorgeschichte. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal zum Anfang noch mal ein bisschen weiter zurückspulen, weil wir hatten letztes Mal nur Rosetta wirklich beleuchtet und Philae selber nicht. Vielleicht fangen wir auch noch mal kurz mit dir selber an, was dein Weg hier zu dieser Position gewesen ist, wie kommt man überhaupt in die Raumfahrt?
Na, wie kommt man in die Raumfahrt? Ich habe Geophysik studiert und Geophysik ist eben nicht nur Geo von der Erde, sondern auch dann Planeten und Sonnensystem und habe dann promoviert schon im Bereich der Erkundung anderer Planeten und Monde, konkret war da Titan, Heuchin-Mission, noch das Gespräch. Wo war das Studium? In Graz, ich habe in Graz studiert. Ich war dann bei der ESA in Estec als Postdoc Research Fellow und bin dann von dort zum DLR gekommen und dann auch schon sehr früh damit begonnen, einen Lander zu entwickeln, zu designen, auszudenken, der zunächst noch Roland hieß, ein bisschen kleiner war und aus dem dann letztlich Philae geworden ist.
Gab es diesen Roland dann auch oder war das nur so eine Idee?
Roland für Rosetta Lander war der ursprüngliche Vorschlag für die Rosetta-Mission, für so einen Lander. Damals gab es noch zwei Lander-Vorschläge, einer eben dieser Roland, der andere ein Champignon von einem Konsortium mit NASA, JPL, mit CNES, mit Frankreich zusammen. Und letztlich gab es dann auch politische Funding-Gründe, warum dieser Champignon nicht zustande gekommen ist und stattdessen ist der Roland-Lander gewachsen. CNES wurde Partner, wir haben die französischen Partner an Bord genommen, der Lander wurde größer, hieß dann viele Jahre Rosetta Lander, nicht besonders originell, bis kurz vor der Landung im Rahmen eines Wettbewerbs der Name Philae ausgewählt wurde.
Das ist diese Insel?
Philae ist eine Insel im Nil, darauf steht ein Tempel. Bevor dem Tempel war ein Obelisk und auf diesem Obelisk ist eine Inschrift und die hat auch geholfen, die ägyptischen Hieroglyphen zu entziffern.
Und wie ja auch Rosetta schon so ein bisschen der Hinweis ist...
Das ist die Parallele zum Stein von Rosetta, Rosetta Stein, der Obelisk von Philae, beide im Übrigen jetzt in England, als Schlüsselelemente für das Verständnis der Geschichte Ägyptens und eben dann die Parallele der Mission, der Raumfahrtmission als Schlüsselelement für das Verständnis der Geschichte unseres Sonnensystems.
Wann war das?
1994 wurde das erste Preliminary Proposal an die ESA eingereicht, dann 1995 ein endgültiges, besser ausgearbeitetes, eben noch für die zwei Lander und dann kurz danach die Verschmelzung zu dem einen größeren Lander. Also etwa zehn Jahre Entwicklungszeit, zehn Jahre Großphase.
War das eigentlich von vornherein vorgesehen, zu landen? Also war die Rosetta-Mission von vornherein schon gedacht, einen Lander zu haben?
Die ganz ursprüngliche Idee der Rosetta-Mission war ja zusammen mit NASA eine Comet Surface Sample Return-Mission zu machen. Also man wollte Probenmaterial von den Kometen zurück zur Erde bringen. Das hat sich sehr früh zerschlagen, konnte also nicht unterstützt werden von amerikanischer Seite. Dann wollte man die Mission an sich in Europa retten, hat unter dem gleichen Namen eine Rendezvous-Mission initiiert und auch beschlossen, die Rosetta-Mission, wie wir sie heute kennen, und hat die Möglichkeit eröffnet, als Nutzlast-Element, ähnlich wie die Kameras oder die Spektrometer, die am Orbiter sind, auch ein oder zwei sogenannte Surface Science Packages vorzuschlagen. Diese Vorschläge waren eben dann Roland und Champignon.
Und das wurde dann relativ schnell auch beschlossen?
Das wurde beschlossen, wurde ausgewählt. Das ist natürlich, man braucht politische Konsortiumsbildung, weil es nicht möglich war für einen Partner alleine, so ein doch aufwendiges Instrument, so ein Surface Package zu bauen. Und daher hat man im Konsortium gebildet. In Deutschland waren die treibenden Kräfte, neben dem DLR, die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft mit zwei Instituten.
Wie plant man denn eine Landung auf etwas, was man eigentlich gar nicht kennt? Also die ganzen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse überhaupt zu Kometen waren ja relativ überschaubar.
Das war wirklich die ganz große Herausforderung bei der Rosetta-Lander-Mission, dass man einen Lander designen musste für ein Objekt, das man, wie sie richtig sagten, eben nicht kennt. Wir wussten die Größe nicht, die Schwerkraft nicht, keine Ahnung, wie die Oberfläche aussieht, keine Ahnung, wie die Form aussieht. Das heißt, man musste ein Design entwickeln, das mit einem sehr breiten Rahmen von möglichen Parametern zurechtkommen kann, das stabil ist, was zum Beispiel die Tag-Nacht-Periode angeht, vom Thermaldesign her, das robust ist, was unterschiedliche Oberflächen, Rauchigkeit oder Oberflächenhärten angeht, dass ein robustes Abstiegsszenario durchführen kann, was mit unterschiedlichen Kometengrößen oder unterschiedlichen schweren Beschleunigungen bei diesen Kometen zur Rande kommt. Das ist prinzipiell anders, als wenn man Lander für Mars oder Mond designt, wo man natürlich die Parameter des Zielkörpers, sei es Mars, sei es Mond, relativ gut kennt.
Thermaldesign, also es ist ja wirklich sehr kalt da draußen. Und dazu kommt noch, das Ding ist irgendwie ein Eisklauts, trotzdem hat es mit extremen Temperaturen zu tun.
Es ist eben nicht nur kalt, es ist kalt und heiß. Die Landung hat stattgefunden in drei astronomischen Einheiten, von der Sonne, also dreimal so weit von der Sonne wie die Erde. Da ist es schon hauptsächlich kalt, aber wir mussten damals auch davon ausgehen, dass der Komet auf seinem Weg immer näher zur Sonne, immer heißer wird und dass wir dann auch unter Umständen das Problem der Überhitzung des Landes haben, vor allem wenn im Inneren die Instrumente betrieben werden und Wärme diszipieren. Auch war uns unklar die Tag-Nacht-Periode, was natürlich relevant ist für ein Thermaldesign. Seit Feststand, dass wir zu dem Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko fliegen, das war ja nicht der ursprüngliche Komet und das war auch keineswegs klar, ganz in der Anfangsphase des Designs wusste man auch nicht, wie die Periode, der Tag-Nacht-Zyklus auf diesem Kometen sein würde.
Kann man das überhaupt vorher erahnen? Man wusste ja noch nicht mal so richtig, wie groß das Ding ist.
Ja, also man hatte eine Ahnung von der Größe und man hatte eine sehr gute Vorstellung vom Tag-Nacht-Zyklus, das bekommt man aus den Lichtkurven heraus. Also wenn man so mit astronomischen Methoden, mit Teleskopen den Kometen beobachtet, den Kern, wenn er weit weg ist von der Sonne, dann ist er nicht immer gleich hell, sondern da ist eine Fluktuation drauf und das liegt eben daran, dass er sich dreht und wenn man diese Periode misst, dann kriegt man auch die Tag-Nacht-Zyklus und das wussten wir ziemlich gut. Also da waren die Vorhersagen sehr gut. Was die Größe angeht, dann kann man die Helligkeit messen und dann muss man annehmen, das Albedo, also die Reflexion von dem Kometen, von dem Körper. Man weiß, dass Kometen dunkel sind, man hat eine dunkle Oberfläche angenommen und dann auch gewusst, dass der ungefähr vier Kilometer im Durchmesser haben würde. Das wussten wir dann von astronomischen Beobachtungen. Wir hatten keine Ahnung, dass der so eine bizarre Form hatte, diese Gummientenform. Die Schlussfolgerungen aus der Lichtkurve waren eher ein bisschen kartoffelförmig, also rundlicher. Das war eine große Überraschung dann im Juni, Juli 2014.
Aber man muss schon so den Würfel ein paar Mal rollen lassen vorher und Annahmen machen, über die man eigentlich gar keine Erkenntnisse hat.
Man muss Annahmen machen, weil man sonst ja ein Design nicht entwickeln kann und vor allem die Subsysteme nicht testen kann. Die muss man ja gegen gewisse Parameter testen. Und daher haben wir ein sogenanntes Engineering-Modell des Kometen erstellt mit einigen Parametern, die eben vernünftig eingrenzbar waren. Durchmesser des Kometen, dann kann man eine gewisse Schwerkraft natürlich auch annehmen, wenn man gewisse plausible Dichte annimmt. Aber manches war eben völlig unklar, so wie die wirkliche Form, wie die wirklichen Oberflächeneigenschaften und auch die Härte der Oberfläche war völlig unbekannt. Viele sind davon ausgegangen, es wäre ganz, ganz, ganz weiches Material, wo natürlich Einsinken ein Problem gewesen wäre. Andere sind davon ausgegangen, dass die Oberfläche sehr hart sein könnte. Und in der Tat haben wir jetzt ja auch beobachtet, dass zumindest Teile der Oberfläche hart sind wie Eis.
Wann wurde dann der Länder gebaut?
Na ja, gut, im Rahmen des Vorschlags 1994-95, dann beginnt man mit einer Phase A, B, wo man Studienberechnungen durchführt. Und dann in den späten 90ern, Anfang der 2000er, wurde der Lander in einigen Modellen, zunächst ein Strukturthermal-Modell und ein elektrisches Qualifikationsmodell und schließlich das eigentliche Flugmodell gebaut. Da war dann 2002 fertig, wurde an die ESA geliefert und der ursprünglich vorgesehene Starttermin wäre ja 2003 gewesen. Da wäre eben der Lander nicht nur an die ESA geliefert gewesen, sondern auch schon getestet zusammen mit dem Rosetta Spacecraft. Das ging ja noch mal durch Thermaltests, Vibrationstests etc.
Wie kommt man denn auf die Größe? Das Ding ist etwa so ein Meter mal ein Meter groß, so ein Kubikmeter.
So ungefähr 100 Kilogramm Masse. Und das ist dann letztlich auch das, was die Verhandlungsmasse ist oder was man sehen muss, was für so eine Raummission zur Verfügung steht. Man kann nicht beliebig viel Masse mit der Ariane 5 zu einem Kometen bringen. Man braucht dann mehr Treibstoff auf der Rosetta-Sonde für die Bahnmanöver, wenn man schwerere Experimente hat. Insofern ist Masse eine sehr, sehr wertvolle Ressource. Ich habe es erwähnt, diese ersten Vorschläge für Roland und Jean Puyon, die waren jeweils für 45 Kilogramm ausgeschrieben. Na gut, die wurden dann kombiniert, dann haben wir mal Richtung 85 Kilo gearbeitet. Das wird immer ein bisschen schwerer letztlich. Und der eigentliche Lander hat jetzt ziemlich genau 100 Kilo, ein bisschen unter 100 Kilogramm.
Wie arbeitet man dann in dem Team, wenn man so etwas abstimmt? Ich meine, dann kommt irgendwie so die Philae-Gruppe und sagt, na ja, wir hätten gerne noch ein bisschen mehr, weil das Instrument wäre ja auch nochmal interessant und wir müssen jetzt noch die Konstruktion machen. Habt ihr das also?
Letztlich ist es der Projektmanager, in dem Fall eben von Rosetta von ESA-Seite, mit dem man das verhandeln kann. Ein gewisser verhandelbarer Spielraum ist, aber der ist nicht sehr groß, weil ja der Projektleiter letztlich sicherstellen muss, dass die Raumsonde im Gesamten nicht zu schwer wird und man die Mission auch mit gewissen Sicherheitsmargins fliegen kann und die Ariane 5 letztlich ausreichend ist, die Sonde zum Kometen zu bringen. Sicher, da kann man mal mit guten Argumenten ein Kilo raus schinden, das ist auch in den Projektmargins drin. Man kann mit anderen Partnern verhandeln, ob die vielleicht weniger Masse brauchen, das kommt sehr selten vor, dass irgendjemand weniger Masse braucht. Letztlich ist es dann doch das Management des Project Managers, in dem Fall eben von Rosetta, der sicherstellt, dass das Gesamtsystem im Rahmen dessen bleibt, was man mit einer Ariane fliegen kann. Und meine Position andererseits war es wieder sicherzustellen, dass eben der Lander nicht schwerer wird, die Experimente im Rahmen bleiben, auch die Subsysteme im Rahmen bleiben, dass wir einen Gesamtlander abliefern, der dann nur geringfügig schwerer ist, als die ursprünglich vorgesehene Masse.
Gab es denn eigentlich irgendwelche Vorbilder? Ich meine, man muss ja diesen Lander jetzt erst mal irgendwie bauen. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, ich wäre jetzt mit dieser Aufgabe konfrontiert, einen Lander zu bauen. Da muss man sich ja erst mal überlegen, wie lande ich? Wie bleibe ich irgendwie an diesem Ding haften? Wie bleibe ich drauf? Gab es irgendwelche anderen Ländersysteme, die man sich angeschaut hat? War Mondlandung da in irgendeiner Form ein Thema?
Man schaut natürlich auf andere Landersysteme, aber es gab keine Lander, die wirklich auf kleinen Körpern bis dorthin gelandet sind. Es gab von den Sowjets die Phobos-Mission zu dem Mars-Mond-Phobos. Die Lander sind leider nicht zum Einsatz gekommen, weil die Sonde vorher schon verloren gegangen war. Das war so am nächsten dran. Also es wäre auch eine Landung gewesen, auf einem kleinen Körper mit niedriger Gravitation. Also sind wir wirklich ziemlich frei von früheren Designs. In diese Aufgabe gegangen, wie kann man auf einem Körper landen, dessen Gravitation so ungefähr ein Hunderttausendstel von der Erdbeschleunigung ist, auf dem man sich vermutlich verankern muss. Wie kann man da aus einem Orbit, und die Orbitalgeschwindigkeit ist ihm ganz gering, einige zehn Zentimeter pro Sekunde, einen Lander absetzen, welche Möglichkeiten hatten. Und wir haben in dieser, ich habe es erwähnt, Phase A, wo man also Studien macht, natürlich unterschiedliche Konzepte in Erwägung gezogen, auch jetzt mehr so einen kugeligen Lander, der dann wie ein Ei sich langsam aufklappt, oder eine große Schraube, die mit ein bisschen Schwung hinunter geschossen wird, auf die Oberfläche an sich dann gleich fest schraubt und dadurch verankert. Also wir hatten da einige Ideen. Letztlich hat sich herauskristallisiert, dieses System mit einem Dreibein ein bisschen konservativ ausschaut, aber wo sehr viel Technologie und Gehirnschmal drinsteht, in dem Dämpfungsmechanismus in diesem zentralen Rohr und dem Mechanismus von diesem Landebein.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Idee war, unten so flexible Flüsse dran zu haben, mit denen man aufsetzt, aber wo der entstehende Schwung vom Absetzen quasi kompensiert wird.
Das Wichtige war, die Impact-Energie, die kinetische Energie zu disziplieren, so dass sie nicht als Federkraft in den Beinen ist, weil das hätte und hat ja letztlich auch zu einem Abprallen geführt. Es ist also nicht so sehr die Gefahr, dass der Lander zerschellen würde. Die Auftriffgeschwindigkeit war ein Meter pro Sekunde. Das ist nicht so schlimm. Das ist ein Problem bei Mondlandern oder Marslandern. Aber eben die Gefahr, dass man dann abprallt, weil die Beine ja in gewisser Weise eine Feder darstellen. Daher dieser Dämpfungsmechanismus im Zentralteil des Landesgeräts. Und er hat ja auch gut funktioniert, hat einen Großteil der Impact-Energie. Und daher ist der Lander nur ein bisschen abgeprallt, obwohl die Harponen nicht funktioniert haben. Und obwohl dieses Kaltgassystem, das wir auch vorgesehen hatten, und den Lander auf der Oberfläche, auf die Oberfläche zu drücken, letztlich nicht funktioniert hat.
Genau, auf die Landung wollte ich gleich noch mal im Detail zu sprechen kommen. Im Prinzip drei Systeme waren vorgesehen. Quasi landen mit Füßen, dann sich festkrallen, so möglich. Als auch nach oben hin ein Strahl pusten.
Mit einem Halkas-System, genau.
Das heißt, es gab keine Vorbilder?
Ja, also wie gesagt, es gab keine Vorbilder, außer vielleicht dieser Phobos-Mission der Sowjets. Da gab es einen Lander, der sich auch mit Ankerhapunnen auf der Oberfläche festgeschossen hätte. Der kam aber nicht zum Einsatz, weil die ganze Sonde, leider Gottes, in den 90ern, bevor sie Phobos erreicht hat, verloren gegangen ist.
Aber wie testet man denn sowas? Das ist mit der hohen Gravitation ganz einfach.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Testmöglichkeiten. Was wir vor dem Start gemacht haben, waren Pendeltests. Also man hat es einfach gegen eine vertikale Wand gelandet. Dadurch simuliert man diese niedrige Schwerkraft, weil der Lander ja von der vertikalen Wand wieder abprallen kann. Der hängt an einem Pendel mit einer Nachführung. Das hat natürlich Nachteile, weil man da nicht simulieren kann, wie man auf weichen Material landet. Man kann ja weichen Sand nicht vertikal aufschichten. Das sind Probleme. Wir haben dann später, allerdings erst nach dem Start, eine Anlage im DLR in Bremen bekommen. Eine Lama-Anlage, wo man mit einem Roboter die Schwerkraft de facto wegrechnet. Das heißt, so ein Lander-Modell wurde dann befestigt an so einem Industrie-Roboter. Und er hat immer eingeh, einmal das Gewicht, die Kraft des Landers weggerechnet. Und dann konnte man auch versuchen, in Sand, Material und unter gewissen Winkeln zu landen. Und das hat uns dann auch bestätigt, dass unser Design nicht so schlecht war und gut funktioniert. Aber natürlich wäre es zu spät gewesen, hier nochmal die Hardware zu ändern.
Das heißt, diese drei Mechanismen, wie war denn das Gefühl vorher? Passt schon?
Naja, wenn man drei Systeme hat, fühlt man sich schon ein bisschen sicherer. Selbst wenn eins ausfällt, sind ja immer noch zwei da. Gut, es sind dann zwei ausgefallen, war immer noch eines da. Die größte Angst hatten wir davor, dass wir nicht auf einem flachen Gebiet landen, sondern irgendwo, wo ein Steilstück ist, also entweder ein Boulder, also ein Brocken unter einem Bein liegt, oder dass wir eben genau auf einem Cliff landen, und dann hätte sich der Lander überschlagen. Das ist Gott sei Dank nicht passiert, aber das war eine nicht zu vernachlässigende Gefahr, wenn man sich so das Landegebiet anzieht und die Unsicherheit, wo wir darauf landen hätten können, dann waren doch einige Cliffs und viele, viele solche Brocken, die da herumgelegen wären. Und wenn wir Pech gehabt hätten, hätte sich der Lander eben dort überschlagen.
Das ist nicht passiert. Was für Instrumente waren jetzt an Bord? Also es waren, glaube ich, 10 Stück?
Es sind 10 PI-Instrumente an Bord mit unterschiedlichsten Zielsetzungen. Das sind zum einen die Kamera-Instrumente, Schieber, eine Panoramakamera, die rundherum insgesamt 7 Kameraköpfe hat, von der man eben so ein bisschen das Bild bekommt, wie wenn ein Astronaut aus dem Fenster schauen würde, rundherum.
Das war eine stereoskopische Kamera?
Eine davon war stereoskopisch, und die anderen rundherum waren Einzelköpfe, also 6 x 60 Grad. Und eine davon stereoskopisch, daher 7 Kameraköpfe. Und dann hatten wir die Kamera, die nach unten blickt, das ist die Rolis-Kamera, die schon im Anflug Bilder gewonnen hat mit immer besserer Auflösung vom ersten Touchdown. Und mit der wir dann auch Bilder gewonnen haben nach der Landung, sogenannte Cook-Aufnahmen, Close-Up-Camera-Bilder aus wenigen 10 cm Entfernung, wo man mit sehr hoher Auflösung des Unterhalb des Landes in der Hand sieht, so viel zu den Kamerainstrumenten. Die große wissenschaftliche Aufgabe war es ja, die Zusammensetzung des Komentenmaterials zu messen. Das erlaubt die Rückschlüsse auf Entstehungsgeschichte des Sonnensystems, organische Chemie, auch Rückschlüsse auf Entstehung des Lebens auf der Erde. Da sind an Bord zwei sogenannte Evolved Gas Analyzers, Instrumente, die Proben, die man vorher in Öfchen platziert, die dann erhitzt werden, analysieren können mit Massenspektrometern und Gaschromatographen. Die Instrumente kann man auch betreiben, ohne die Gase vorher im Öfchen zu erhitzen, in einem sogenannten Sniffing Mode, also einfach die Atmosphäre, die unmittelbar über der Oberfläche ist, mit dem Massenspektrometer analysieren. Ein Instrument Ptolemy aus England, von der Open University, war in erster Linie darauf ausgelegt, Isotopenverhältnisse zu messen, zum Beispiel Sauerstoffisotopen. Ein anderes Instrument vom Max-Planck-Institut für Sonnensystemforschung in Göttingen, damals noch Lindau im Harz. COSAC war eher darauf ausgerichtet, die organische Chemie zu untersuchen. Ein weiteres Analyseinstrument war das sogenannte APX, Alpha Particle X-Ray Spektrometer. Ein ganz ähnliches Instrument, wie es auch auf den Marsrohren ist, auch aus Mainz vom selben PI, vom selben Team. Da regt man mit einer ganz kleinen Menge radioaktiven Materials Atome von der zu untersuchenden Oberfläche an und misst dann die Rückstreuung Alpha Teilchen und Rhöhnkünststrahlung und bekommt die Elementzusammensetzung. Eine andere Gruppe von Instrumenten war darauf ausgerichtet, die physikalischen Eigenschaften des Kometen zu messen. Zum Beispiel Härte, aber auch die elektrizitätskonstante, akustische Eigenschaften. Mein Instrument, das heißt MOPUS, ein Tele aus Berlin, war vorgesehen, so ein Stachel in den Boden hinein zu rammen und dann auch die Temperatur zu messen, die Härte zu messen. Thermal Mapper, der die Oberflächentemperatur misst. Anderes Instrument, Sesam, besteht aus mehreren Komponenten. Zum einen akustische Sensoren in den Füßen, die im Übrigen auch sehr schön den Touchdown selbst gemessen haben. Kann man sich im Internet anhören, das Krachen von dem ersten Touchdown. Man kann es außer sich es nur anzuhören, auch dann wissenschaftlich analysieren, was das wirklich bedeutet zur Korngröße und Tiefe dieser obersten Schicht. Das sind Arbeiten, die jetzt im Augenblick noch durchgeführt werden. Zum anderen ein Dust Impact Monitor DIMM, also so eine Art Piezos, wo man Staubweilchen detektieren kann, die zurückfallen auf den Lander und eine Permittivity Probe, um die elektrischen Eigenschaften der Oberfläche zu messen. Wehrmannbord, ein Radar-Instrument, Konzert, wo man Radar-Signale, Radarwellen zwischen Orbiter und Lander hin und her schicken kann und wenn der Komet dazwischen ist, bekommt man also Daten über den inneren Aufbau während eines Scans bzw. die globalen, die elektrischen Eigenschaften des Komets.
Das fand ich ja schon eine der pfiffigeren Instrumenten. Ich meine, die sind alle relativ pfiffig, aber dass man an der Stelle wirklich mit dem Orbiter zusammen eine Messung macht.
Ja, pfiffig ist auch zum ersten Mal so gemacht worden. Liegt natürlich auch ein bisschen daran, dass das nur bei einem kleinen Körper geht, wirklich mit Radarsignalen, denen zu durchleuchten. Und es ist ja auch wirklich gelungen, dass man zwischen Lander und Orbiter die Radarsignale durchgeschickt hat und auch diese Daten werden im Augenblick gerade ausgewertet oder demnächst veröffentlicht zu werden von diesem einen Scan, den man in der kurzen Zeit durchführen konnte, durch den Komenten. Das Instrument wurde dann auch genutzt als eine Art Ranging-System, um zu triangulieren, wo der Lander genau ist, weil nach dem Sprung wussten wir ja nicht, wo er genau ist. Und mit diesem Instrument konnte man das relativ genau herausfinden. Dann noch die letzte Kategorie, die ich noch hier erwähnt habe, das RoMAB-Instrumenten, Magnetometer, Plasmamonitor, mit dem man die magnetischen und Plasmaeigenschaften des Komenten gemessen hat.
Das ist der Fluxkompensator, oder?
Also ein Fluxgate ist einfach ein Begriff für einen Magnetometer, das aus Spulen aufgebaut ist, mit dem man das Magnetfeld sehr gut messen kann. Das ist traditionell auf der Erde verwendet, auch um zum Beispiel Effekte in der Ionosphäre zu messen. Da hat man herausgefunden, dass der Komet tatsächlich kaum ein Magnetfeld hat. Nun hat man natürlich nicht angenommen, dass er ein Magnetfeld hat wie die Erde mit einem inneren Dynamo. Aber es hätte durchaus sein können, dass bei der Bildung des Kometen, also die Stoppteilchen, die zum Teil auch magnetisch sind, dass sich die ausrichten, wenn nämlich in der Frühphase des Sonnensystems schon ein Magnetfeld bestanden hätte, ein Interplanetaris, das konnte nicht bestätigt werden. Also ganz offensichtlich gab es da noch kein Magnetfeld in der frühen Phase, als die Kometen oder zumindest dieser eine Kometen sich aggregiert haben.
Einen haben wir glaube ich noch vergessen.
Einen haben wir vergessen, das ist das Dabora selbst, der eben diese Ilvold Gas Analyzers mit dem Proben in den Öfchen bedienen hätte sollen. Der wurde auch als Instrument gezählt, weil man natürlich auch aus dem Bohren und dem Bohrvorsprung einige Daten über die physikalischen Eigenschaften hätte gewinnen können.
Hier in dem Gebäude, wo wir sitzen, ist ja auch das Länderkontrollzentrum, wo wahrscheinlich ordentlich Betrieb war, als es dann soweit war. Sind dann diese ganzen Wissenschaftler mit ihren Instrumenten dann auch hier vor Ort gewesen?
Von allen Wissenschaftsteams gab es hier Krüppchen, die hier vertreten waren und die haben auch direkt hier ihre Daten empfangen. Und auch hier haben dann manche Treffen stattgefunden, um die nächsten Schritte in der Science Community zu diskutieren. Also die waren alle zumindest repräsentiert hier, alle Instrumente, auch alle Verantwortlichen und Experten für die Subsysteme im Übrigen und der Lander selbst wurde eben vom LCC hier in Köln, vom DLR, kommandiert.
Wird das mal wieder erstaunlich, wie umfangreich so ein Team auch aufgestellt sein muss? Also wie viel unterschiedliche Expertise natürlich da ist, um diese ganze Technik überhaupt zu steuern, aber auch wie enorm die Zusammenarbeit dann ist in der kurzen Zeit. Weil hier war es ja, weil es gibt ja Missionen, da fliegt man dann halt los und dann ist man irgendwann da und dann hat man in gewisser Hinsicht auch Zeit. Hier lief ja irgendwie von Anfang an die Uhr.
Jaja, also wir sind zwar lange hingeflogen, aber dann war die Zeit kurz, zum einen war sie schon mal geplantermaßen kurz, nämlich die Zeit zwischen den ersten besseren Daten von Kometen nach Ankunft von Rosetta im Sommer 2014 bis zur Landung im November mussten wir den Kometen charakterisieren und auch einen Landeplatz auswählen, dieses Landes-Szenario ausarbeiten. Das ist nicht so trivial in der kurzen Zeit, das ist glaube ich auch in so schneller Zeit, bis jetzt noch nie gemacht worden, dass man so spät die Daten über den Zielkörper erfährt, wo man dann kurz danach landen möchte. Und das hat nur funktioniert, weil die Experimentatoren von den Orbiter-Experimenten wirklich sehr, sehr kooperativ, sehr schnell uns nicht nur die Rotarten, sondern eben auch Produkte geliefert haben. Also wirklich eine Karte von den Komenten, ein dreidimensionales Modell von den Komenten.
Vielleicht müssen wir an dieser Stelle noch mal kurz ein bisschen auch zusammenfassen, weil das wird natürlich jetzt auch nicht jeder so im Detail mitverfolgt haben. Also Rosetta hat einen sehr langen Weg angetreten, hat mehrere Schwinge geholt im Sonnensystem, verschiedene Flybys gemacht. Dann kam diese lange Phase der Hibernation, wo das Gerät fast vollständig ausgeschaltet war, wurde dann wieder erweckt. Das war dann so 2014, so der erste große Moment, wo man merkte, jetzt steigt so langsam die Anspannung auch an. Ab dem Moment, wo Rosetta wieder eingeschaltet wurde, gab es dann relativ schnell schon Bilder.
Na ja gut, man hat sich dann zwischen Januar und April, Mai stückweise dem Kometen genähert, es gab Bilder, die waren zunächst allerdings noch nicht so aufschlussreich. Also die waren wichtig für die Navigation, um sich wirklich an den Kometen heranzubirschen.
Also man wusste vor allem erst mal, man ist am richtigen Ort.
Also man ist am richtigen Ort, da ist ein Komet, da fliegen wir hin, weil man ihm von der Erde nicht so genau die Position bestimmen kann, wie sie notwendig ist, wenn man dann in den Orbit drum geht. Also da gab es Bilder, auch von Rosetta, aber die haben uns zunächst im Frühjahr 2014 zum Beispiel noch nicht gezeigt, wie die Form aussieht. Das haben wir dann Juni, Juli erst erkannt, als man näher beim Kometen war, das ist ja eine Badeente, eine ganz bizarre Form. Und dann im August erst die Oberflächen.
Das heißt, die Form war sozusagen die erste relevante Information?
Die erste Information, die wir erst von Rosetta bekommen haben. Die Tag-Nacht-Zyklus, den konnte man von der Erde aus messen. Eine ungefähre Vorstellung von der Größe hatten wir auch. Die Bahn im Prinzip, das Komenten kannte man auch, wenn auch nicht genau genug, um dann in den Orbit einzuschießen. Aber die Gestalt, die Form, die haben wir erst auf den Rosetta-Bildern erkannt.
Das war aber jetzt erstmal nur eine Überraschung. Das hat jetzt noch keine unmittelbaren Konsequenzen für die weiteren Kranen.
Na ja, die Konsequenz war, dass man nicht überall landen kann. Man kann natürlich auch auf so einem Binary oder so einem Körper mit einem tiefen Tal oder Haus 2 aufgebaut, wie man sehen will. Oder bleiben wir einfach beim Analog- und der Badeente. Man kann dort landen, aber man kann nicht überall landen. Es wäre sehr schwierig gewesen, in dem Hals der Badeente zu landen zum Beispiel. Aber eben am Kopf oder am Schwänzchen der Ente konnte man besser landen. Wir haben dann auch verifiziert die Position der Rotationsachse. Also man kannte die Rotationsperiode. Aber wie die Achse steht, das gab es zwar gewisse Vermutungen, aber das konnte man auch erst mit den Daten von Rosetta wirklich fix machen. Das heißt, man wusste dann erst genau, wie die Beleuchtung aussieht, wie hohe ist Sommer, wo ist Winter, wie sieht das aus. Und das ist natürlich relevant, wenn man auf einem sommerlich schön beleuchteten Platz landen möchte, was wir wollten.
Das heißt, erst nach zwei, drei Monaten...
Joli, Joli, Joli, eigentlich haben wir dann die Form herausgefunden. Am 6. August war dann die offizielle Orbit in Serschen oder Ankunft beim Kometen. Ein bisschen irreführender Begriff Orbit in Serschen. Es war kein wirklich gebundener Orbit, sondern Pyramidorbit hat man das genannt, dass man ein bisschen in Fluchtgeschwindigkeit bleibt. Aber in der Nähe. Warum eigentlich das Kometen? Naja, wenn man nicht in einem gebundenen Orbit ist, um den Körper, dessen Masse und Schwerkraft man nicht so genau kennt, gibt man kein Risiko, irgendwann mal drauf zu krauchen. Wenn das Spacecraft in den Safe Mode geht oder man Kontakt verliert, dann trifft es einfach ganz langsam weg. Und wenn man dann Stunden, Tage, selbst schlimmst zwei Wochen später, erst wieder Kontrolle über das Spacecraft kriegt, dann kann man mit relativ geringen Bahnmanövern wieder näher ranzukommen und man hat nie die Gefahr, drauf zu krachen.
Das heißt, das war der Grund für diesen dreieckigen Orbit, der so gesagt wurde?
Genau, zuerst in etwa 100 Kilometer, dann in etwa 50 Kilometer Entfernung und dann eben wirklich in gebundenen, wirklichen Orbit in 30, 20 und dann für kurze Zeit sogar 10 Kilometer Orbit.
Wie nah musste Rosetta dann kommen, um jetzt wirklich für viele, für die Landung relevante Kartendaten zu finden?
Ja, es war alles relevant, auch aus 100 Kilometer, das waren relevante Daten und auf Basis derer haben wir auch unsere Vorauswahl möglicher Ländeplätze gemacht und dann ist Rosetta noch näher rangekommen, dann haben wir diese vorausgewählten fünf Landeplätze mit höherer Detailgenauigkeit noch mal untersucht und konnten dann wählen, welcher Platz ist sicherer als ein anderer, wo sind weniger Cliffs, wo sind weniger Bowler drauf.
Fünf, also es wurden ja glaube ich fast nicht, wie viele waren es insgesamt? Es wurden mehrere benannt.
Ende August sind wir mit fünf Kandidaten ins Rennen gegangen. Mitte September hat man das eingeschränkt bereits auf ein Nominal- und ein Backup-Landing-Site und im Oktober, ziemlich genau einen Monat vor der tatsächlichen Landung haben wir dann bestätigt das Nominal-Landing-Site. Das Nominelle, da hätte man auch nochmal mit den neu gewonnenen Daten, wenn man festgestellt hat, um Gottes Willen, das Nominal-Landing-Site ist ein ganz schlimmes, hätte man nochmal auf das Backup-Site umschwenken können.
Was waren denn dann die primären Kriterien für die Auswahl des Landeplatzes?
Die technischen Kriterien kann man einteilen in solche, die die Beleuchtung betreffen. Man wollte eben auf der Sommerhemisphäre landen, viel Licht und die Long-Term-Science zu machen. Dann gab es die Kriterien der Bahndynamik, wo kann man in relativ kurzer Zeit sicher vom Orbiter abgetrennt dort auch landen. Einige Landeplätze hätten einen Abstieg von einigen 10 Stunden gefordert, das wollte man eben vermeiden. Es wäre sehr schwierig gewesen in Gebieten wie zum Beispiel der Nacken von diesem Doppelkörper zu landen. Und dann natürlich die Kriterien der Oberflächenrauigkeit. Wir hatten ja eine sogenannte Landeellipse, das ist also der Bereich der Landeungenauigkeit, von dem man ausgeht, irgendwo da drin kann man landen. Und dann kann man Statistik betreiben, wie viel Prozent des Gebietes in dieser Landeellipse hat eine Hanglage über 30 oder über 45 Grad. Und wenn das ein geringer Prozentsatz ist und die meiste Gegend relativ flach ist, dann ist das ein guter Landeplatz. Und wenn man aber viele Bereiche mit hohen Cliffs hat, dann ist es ein riskanter und nicht so guter Landeplatz. Ähnliches kann man mit einer Boulder-Statistik machen. Man zählt, wie viel so Brocken über einer gewissen Größe liegen da rum und wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man so einen trifft. Und auch dann kann man eben diese Landing-Sites vom Risiko her bewerten. Darüber hinaus gab es natürlich die wissenschaftlichen Argumente bei der Landing-Sites-Selection. Allerdings hat man auch erkannt, dass jeder Ort auf dem Kometen eigentlich wissenschaftlich interessant war. Insofern waren diese Argumente dann, wir haben nicht mehr zu einer besonders wilden Diskussion geführt. Es gab keine klare Präferenz für eine Gegend aus wissenschaftlichen Gründen.
Ah, weil man ja letztlich eh nicht vorher wusste, was einen erwartet.
Ja, und ein Komet ist auch relativ homogen, was so seine Oberfläche angeht. Man hat zumindest damals noch keine Plätze identifiziert, wo blankes Eis oder ganz klare Aktivität wäre. Der sieht schon relativ ähnlich aus, egal wo man landet. Es ist so eine Art Krater auf dem Kopf des Kometen, wer sich die Bilder ansieht, das wollten wir dann lieber vermeiden, wenn man davon ausgegangen ist, dass durch den Impact oder was immer dieses Krater gebildet hat, vielleicht auch das ursprüngliche Material verändert oder kompaktiert ist. Da gab es ein bisschen Argumente dagegen. Aber ansonsten wäre jeder Platz auf dem Kometen wissenschaftlich interessant gewesen. Und es gab auch niemanden, der gesagt hätte, das ist langweilig, da will ich nicht landen.
Aber das Licht war relevant?
Das Licht war relevant. Wir haben einen Landeplatz gesucht und ausgewählt, der auf der Sommerhemisphäre war. Und auch dieser erste Touchdown-Punkt von viele. Da hatten wir am Tag ungefähr 7 Stunden Sonne und 5 Stunden Nacht gehabt. Das wäre sehr schön gewesen. Aber wie Sie wissen, viele wollten nicht bleiben, weil der Sonnenboden ist wieder abgeprallt und ist dann eben leider an einer Gegend gelandet, wo sehr wenig Sonnenlicht auf den Lander trifft.
Philae war ja quasi so ein bisschen der Rucksack von Rosetta, hatte da so seinen eigenen Bereich und hat aber ja selber gar keinen eigenen Antrieb gehabt. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt über Landung nachdenkt, dann hat man was weiß ich im Kopf, Mondlandung vielleicht, dass man da so rausfliegt und dann so mit Düsen landet. Das war ja nicht der Fall, sondern Philae hatte ja selber eigentlich keinerlei Antriebssysteme, sondern wurde, wenn ich das richtig sehe, eigentlich ja nur rausgeschubst. Stimmt das?
Ja, wurde rausgeschubst mit einer sehr genau vorprogrammierten Geschwindigkeit und mit einer sehr gut vorher eingestellten Richtung, also gezielt abgeworfen. Ja, das war eben das Konzept, dass man mit Rosetta zielt und den Lander, ja de facto, wenn Sie so wollen, im Orbit nach hinten schubst. Und wenn man noch hinten geschubst wird im Orbit, dann fällt man nach unten. Und genau das ist auch bei Philae passiert. Das haben wir dann konkret in 22 Kilometer höher gemacht und der Abstieg war ziemlich genau sieben Stunden. Und das hat sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Dieser Abstoßmechanismus hat ganz, ganz akkurat funktioniert und auch die Bahnregelung und der Einschuss in diesen Delivery Orbit von Rosetta, auch die Ausrichtung von Rosetta zum Zeitpunkt des Abstoßens, das hat alles ganz gut funktioniert. Was schubst denn da überhaupt? In dem Fall haben wir gewählt ein Design mit drei sogenannten Lead Screws, also drei Schrauben, die den Lander wegschrauben, wenn Sie so wollen. Und der Vorteil bei so einem Design im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu einer Feder, ist, dass man durch die Messung der Schraubengeschwindigkeit auch die Abstoßgeschwindigkeit sehr gut mit der Rückkopplung messen kann und dadurch eine Genauigkeit im Abtrennen bekommt, die man mit einer Feder, die irgendwie altert natürlich, wenn die jahrelang oder ein Jahrzehnt durchs All gaukelt, niemals bekommen würde.
Kälte ist dann auch nicht so das Thema, sondern die Dinger sind quasi direkt in Philae reingeschraubt gewesen.
Ja, also da waren die Gegenmuttern auf Philae, drei Schrauben am Orbiter, die Schrauben mit einem Gurt verbunden, dass die synchron laufen und ein Motor und eine Messung, wie schnell die drehen und dann wurde der Motor angesteuert und die Schrauben haben den Lander weggedrückt.
Wie stark war dieser Schubs?
Die Geschwindigkeit, die wir gewählt haben, war ungefähr 18 cm pro Sekunde.
18 cm pro Sekunde?
Das ist sehr langsam.
Also letztlich war viele 18 cm pro Sekunde langsamer als Rosetta im Orbit?
Wenn man so will, langsamer als Rosetta im Orbit und ist daher abgestiegen.
Aber war denn zu diesem Zeitpunkt dieser Orbit, wie hieß es früher so schön, ein normaler Orbit?
Nein, das war ein ganz definierter Delivery Orbit. Also es war ein dediziertes Manöver, ein Einschuss sozusagen in einen Orbit zur Lander Delivery. Der wäre wieder hyperpolisch gewesen.
Das heißt, erst musste Rosetta quasi in den richtigen Orbit gebracht werden. Dann musste man den Zeitpunkt finden und die richtige Rausstoßgeschwindigkeit.
Die richtige Richtung.
Und das zum richtigen Zeitpunkt machen.
Genau.
Und dann...
Und dann trennt sich der Lander und dann fällt er, das Wort ist richtig, weil es eben die Gravitationsbeschleunigung des Komenten verantwortlich dafür ist, fällt der Lander auf die Oberfläche. Und das hat auch wirklich, das hat ganz, ganz wunderbar geklappt.
Man wusste ja die Gravitation vorher nicht genau.
Also, seit man im Orbit war, kannte man zumindest die Masse.
Ich meine, also vorher, bevor man gar nicht da war, wusste man sie nicht wirklich.
Überhaupt nicht.
Wie hat man sie denn dann gemessen?
Wenn man im Orbit ist, und wir waren ja vorher im Orbit, kennt man natürlich die Masse schon, weil ja die Orbitalperiode davon abhängt, wie die Masse des Zentralkörpers ist. Also, die Masse kannte man sehr gut. Was man nicht so gut kannte, das waren die höheren harmonischen, also die Massenverteilung in diesen Komenten, die hätten auch noch einen Fehler bewirken können.
Das bestimmte Teil.
Ich habe gesagt, wir hatten eine Landeungenauigkeit, eine Landeellipse, da gingen Allerlei-Fehler hinein. Ungenauigkeiten, die man befürchtet hat, bei dem Einschuss vom Orbiter in die richtige Bahn, Ungenauigkeiten bei dem Abstoßen in der Geschwindigkeit, aber auch Effekte, den Komenten selbst betreffend zum einen, die Ausgasung, die auch schon war, auch schon bei 3AU, und Unsicherheiten im Gravitationsmodell.
Aber die Masse wurde quasi dadurch gemessen, dass man an dem Komenten vorbeigeflogen ist und nachgemessen hat, wie sehr man von dem Weg angezogen wird.
Genau, wie sehr wird die Bahn von Rosetta abgelenkt durch den Komenten, das kann man sehr gut.
Und ist diese Ungleichförmigkeit des Komentenobjektes, also mit diesem Kopf und dem Boden, heißt das dann auch, dass wirklich sehr unterschiedlich verteilt ist, dass diese Gravitation unregelmäßig ist, oder ist das zu verdrängen?
Ja, also wir haben da eine Näherung gemacht. Wir sind davon ausgegangen, dass diese Masse, die man gemessen hat, vom Schwerpunkt, dass man die verteilt auf einen Körper mit genauer Form von der Ente mit konstanter Dichte. Dann ist man näher dran, als wenn man alles als Punktmasse im Zentrum annehmen würde. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, der Komet hat wirklich keine sehr hohen Dichtegradienten, dass dieses Modell relativ nahe an die Wirklichkeit reinkommt.
Also es ist gleichmäßig verteilt?
Es ist relativ, oder zumindest so weit man das messen konnte, recht gleichmäßig verteilt.
Das heißt, dann wusste man, wie stark zieht der Komet eigentlich wirklich?
Genau.
Sodass dieser Zeitpunkt dann gewählt werden kann.
Dann kann man den Zeitpunkt wählen, kann man die Höhe wählen, kann man die Abstoßgeschwindigkeit wählen oder Höhe und Abstoßgeschwindigkeit korrelieren natürlich. Kann genau zielen und kann auch eben die Bahn berechnen, wie der Lander dann fliegt.
Wie wählt man denn den Zeitpunkt dann aus? Ist das dann schon so, dass man hier dann die richtige Tageszeit hat?
Oder wir haben auch die Tageszeit gewählt. Wir wollten auf jeden Fall bei Tageslicht landen, unter anderem, weil wir ja die Kamera hatten, die nach unten blickt und die kurz vor dem Tag standen.
Also Tageslicht auf dem Landepunkt?
Auf dem Landepunkt zur Zeit der Landung.
Aber ich meine, hat die Tageszeit hier im Kontrollzentrum auch eine Rolle?
Nein, also natürlich die Public Relations-Leute fragen, ob man es nicht zu einer gewissen Sendezeit machen kann. Aber bei so einer Mission war das nicht wirklich das Argument. Das war letztlich, glaube ich, ganz praktisch, ist sich das ausgegangen, auch für die Medien. Aber das war nicht das...
Also man hätte ja auch jede Uhrzeit genommen.
Selbstverständlich, wenn es sicherer gewesen wäre, um zwei hinter früh zu landen, dann wären wir auch um zwei hinter früh gelandet.
So, jetzt ist das Ding rausgeschubst worden. Senkt sich. Das ist, glaube ich, dann auch, also zu dem Zeitpunkt wurden dann alle, also nicht alle Instrumente, aber einige Instrumente, die Kamera zum Beispiel, überhaupt das erste Mal aktiviert.
Naja, also wir haben die Instrumente natürlich auch schon aktiviert, als der Lander noch am Orbiter war.
Alles getestet?
Alle getestet, kalibriert, sogar schon einige wissenschaftliche Messungen gemacht. Einige Instrumente waren schon bei den Asteroiden-Vorbeiflügen eingeschaltet, das Magnetometer zum Beispiel. Man hat auch mit dem Massenspektrometer von den erwähnten Gas-Evolved Gas Analyzers versucht, eine Exosphäre von Lutetia zu messen. Hat nichts gemessen, aber das ist auch eine Information. Man hat auch schon im Orbit die ein bisschen eingeschaltet, nicht nur zu Kalibrationszwecken, aber in erster Linie, um zu kalibrieren und dann bereit zu sein. Also alle Instrumente waren getestet und schon in Betrieb, auch vor Separation.
Und ab dem Moment, wo sich viele jetzt getrennt hat von Rosetta, was war dann quasi das erste Instrument, was so richtig neu zum Einsatz kam? Das war dann die Kamera wahrscheinlich erstmal, oder?
Das waren unterschiedliche Instrumente. Die Kamera ja, aber auch das Konzert, das Radar-Instrumente war bereits in Betrieb, die Evolved Gas Analyzers waren in Betrieb. Wir haben natürlich auch diese, kurz vor dem Touchdown, die erwähnten akustischen Sensoren in den Füßen aktiviert, um den Touchdown selbst zu messen. Also wir hatten einige Instrumente, die schon im Descent, im Abstieg entweder gemessen haben, einige waren auch in Betrieb für Kalibrationen.
War irgendein Instrument jetzt für die Landung überhaupt noch relevant? Eigentlich nicht. Die Landung ab dem Moment war ja komplett...
Die war nicht relevant insofern, als man etwas hätte ändern können. Aber sie waren durchaus relevant insofern, als man die Landung nachher charakterisieren konnte und man Daten gewonnen hat, die dann Rückschlüsse auf zum einen rein jetzt von der Technik her, wie es der Lander abgebräult zugelassen haben, zum anderen aber auch Rückschlüsse über die Eigenschaften des Kometen und Wissenschaft uns gebracht haben.
In welchem mentalen Zustand befindet sich das Team in dem Moment, wo der Lander das Rosetta objektiviert?
Das war Anspannung, aber auch ein bisschen, also ich kann jetzt nicht für alle sprechen. Wir hatten mehr zu tun, als wir dachten. Also man ist ein bisschen abgelenkt davon, dass das in gewisser Weise ein historischer Moment ist, wenn man Entscheidungen treffen muss, man wartet auf die Daten, man schaut auf die Daten. Ja, es war sicher sehr, sehr spannend, aber man war auch abgelenkt durch die Tätigkeiten, durch die Entscheidungen, durch die Daten auf die Mannschaft.
3AU heißt, dass die Daten ungefähr so eine knappe halbe Stunde später auf der Erde ankamen, als es tatsächlich passiert, aber das ist ja egal, das nimmt man ja dann quasi wie Echtzeit wahr. Kamen dann die Daten auch quasi in Echtzeit noch, als der Anflug durchgeführt wurde?
Zwei Stunden nach Separation haben wir begonnen, Daten zu übertragen vom Lander. Und da kamen dann auch schon Daten. Also wir hatten Telemetrie während des Abstiegs.
Aber es gab auch schon vorher das Foto von Rosetta.
Es gab zum Beispiel dieses Fairwell-Image von Schieber, wo man Rosetta drauf sieht. Aber auch andere Daten, Housekeeping-Daten und so weiter. Also wir wussten, dass der Lander unterwegs ist, im Abstieg ist. Wir wussten dann natürlich auch, dass das Landebein gut ausgeklappt ist. Wir wussten, dass das Schwungrad gut funktioniert. Wir wussten auch, dass das Kalkulsystem nicht funktionieren würde.
Das war ja eine Information, die schon vor dem Rausschubsen, oder wie sagt man, Separation, separation, klingt edler. Dass das nicht, weiß nicht, was wusste man?
Man wusste, dass es nicht reportet? Nein, wir haben versucht, den Tank zu öffnen. Der Tank hatte so einen Membran, um sicherzustellen, dass über die zehn Jahre das Stickstoff nicht ausgasen. Und da gab es Probleme. Und wenn der Tank zu ist, kann das nicht funktionieren. Wir haben den Vorgang des Tanköffnens noch ein zweites Mal versucht, jeweils mit redundanten Systemen. Und die Daten haben angezeigt, dass das wohl nicht funktioniert hat. Das heißt, wir mussten davon ausgehen, dass das Kaltgassystem nicht funktioniert. Jetzt bestand die Möglichkeit, die ganze Landung zu verschieben, ein No-Go zu geben. Haben wir nicht gemacht, habe ich nicht entschieden. Hauptsächlich deshalb, weil zwei Wochen warten nichts gebracht hätte. Wir haben es zweimal versucht, wenn man es ein drittes Mal versucht. Okay, da kann man jetzt drüber nachdenken. Im Grunde genommen war klar, wir müssen wohl ohne dieses Kaltgassystem machen.
Das heißt, das Öffnen des Tanks hat nicht funktioniert?
Ja, genau.
Das war so ein Schraubmechanismus, oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Nein, das ist ein Wachsmotor, das mal erhitzt, es dehnt sich aus und es schiebt dann eine Nadel in eine Membran.
Ah, so ein Rein-Piksen sozusagen. Und gibt es irgendeine Ahnung, was daran jetzt nicht geklappt haben kann?
Ja, also es dürfte wohl an der Software letztlich in dem ADS gelegen haben, dass das nicht funktioniert hat. ADS steht für Active Decent System.
Das ist ja schon mal so ein kleiner Downer, oder?
Das war natürlich ein Downer vorher, weil man schon weiß, dass es kritisch ist, also eins von drei funktioniert schon mal nicht. Wir hatten auch einige andere Probleme mit dem Computerbooten, die Tage vor der Landung, das war sehr spannend und ging keineswegs so glatt, wie wir uns das erhofft hatten. Und ging auch nicht so glatt wie viele der Tests, die wir vorher in den Monaten oder in den Jahren zuvor durchgeführt haben.
Was hat da nicht funktioniert?
Ja, wir hatten ein Problem, den Zentralcomputer hochzufahren, den haben wir dann einfach noch mal hochgefahren, dann hat er funktioniert. Aber das macht so ein bisschen ein mulmiges Gefühl. Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Er hat das ja auch so digitales System, das steht ja eigentlich nur in der Erwartung.
Keiner weiß so genau warum, dass es beim ersten Mal nicht funktioniert hat. Das macht es dann spannender, als man es vielleicht braucht.
Das ist ja vor allem auch immer, ich meine, jede Fehlfunktion, da steckt ja dann auch immer eine Person dahinter oder ein kleineres Team.
Ja, also man wird das nicht unbedingt jetzt auf eine Person fixieren, wer dann schuld ist oder den Finger hinzuzeigen. Klar, die Subsysteme kommen von Teams oder auch von Industriepartnern im Falle des Galkas-Systems. Ja, gut.
Ich stelle mir halt nur vor, jeder wünscht sich natürlich, dass das, woran man selber gearbeitet hat, dass das nicht ist, woran es dann hängt. Okay, also, Separation hat stattgefunden, Instrumente fangen an zu laufen, nachdem sie schon mal getestet wurden. Das Ding steigt langsam herab, sieben Stunden ist es unterwegs. Es ist ja so eine leere Zeit. Man weiß, das Ding treibt leine runter. Man wusste, es fliegt auch alles korrekt. Es gab ja auch schon Bilder, was ich schon mal äußerst bemerkenswert finde. Ich glaube, über die Wahrnehmung dieses Projektes von aus müssen wir auch nochmal reden. Aber man wusste, der Länder ist unterwegs. Was war dann die erste Landungsinformation? Also was war das erste Signal?
Wir haben schon die Außendarstellung, die Medien. Die sind natürlich darauf aus, irgendeinen Punkt zu definieren, ab wo man jubeln kann, Champagner öffnen kann etc. Wir haben überlegt, was wäre dieser Punkt? Und sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, ein vernünftiger Punkt, wo man das verkünden kann. Die Landung hat geklappt, bis wenn wir ein Signal haben, das wir den Boden berührt haben und nach wie vor Radiokontakt mit dem Lander besteht. Also ausgeschlossen ist, dass er irgendwie sich überschlagen hat, wie ich erwähnt habe, bei irgendeinem Cliff oder einem Boulder. Das haben wir ja dann auch gemacht. Wir haben verkündet, Lander ist gelandet. Wir haben noch Kontakt. Philae ist Talking to us. Begeisterung in den Medien war groß. Minuten später haben wir allerdings auch schon gewusst, irgendetwas stimmt nicht. Der Lander ist immer noch in Bewegung. Ja, wir sind gelandet. Ja, wir haben Kontakt nach wie vor zum Lander. Aber nein, er ist nicht verankert und er ist immer noch in Bewegung. Der Solargenerator hat Paneele rundherum angezeigt. Der Lander dreht sich. Die Instrumente haben ganz klar angezeigt, wir bewegen uns. Also wir wussten, wir sind irgendwie abgeprallt. Wir wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, wie und wohin. Ungefähr zwei Stunden später ist der Lander dann zum Stillstand gekommen. Wir hatten immer noch Kommunikation mit dem, immer noch Kontakt. Und dann haben wir uns schon ein bisschen besser gefüllt. Dann wussten wir, wir sind irgendwo. Wir wissen zwar nicht, wo. Wir sind an der Oberfläche, aber wir können mit dem Lander kommunizieren. Wir sind zwar nicht verankert, aber im Prinzip spricht nichts dagegen, nun unser Messprogramm durchzuführen.
Weil jetzt läuft ja die Zeit doppelt. Weil jetzt der Strom kommt zunächst einmal aus den Batterien und was man noch zusätzlich an Licht aufsammeln kann. Aber irgendwann ist ja vorbei mit dem Licht.
Genau, das wussten wir nicht unmittelbar nach diesem, der Lander ist jetzt irgendwo gelandet. Wie dunkel die Stelle ist, wo wir gelandet sind. Aber wir wussten, wir haben ja Batteriekapazität für so zweieinhalb Tage an Bord. Das heißt, das war dann schon mal wirklich eine gute Nachricht. Wir sind irgendwo auf diesen Komenten, wir können kommunizieren, wir haben nach wie vor fast volle Batterie. Und wir können jetzt ein Messprogramm durchführen. Aber wir müssen das Messprogramm ändern, weil wir eben nicht verankert sind, weil wir nicht wissen, wie wir auf der Oberfläche sind. Und daher haben wir es nicht riskiert gleich zu anfangen, zum Beispiel zu bohren. Das haben wir dann erst zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt in dieser Sequenz verschoben.
Sind denn die Bohrer, die sich jetzt eigentlich in die Oberfläche reindrehen sollten, haben die wirklich angefangen zu bohren? Oder sind die gar nicht erst gestartet?
Es gibt sogenannte Eisschrauben in den Füßen, die hätten den Lander verankern sollen. Die bohren sich nicht aktiv, sondern einfach durch den Aufpressdruck beim Touchdown hätten sich über einen Seilzug diese Schrauben rausgedreht. Die haben sich nicht rausgedreht oder nur ganz wenig. Das liegt daran, dass die Oberfläche, zumindest die wo wir jetzt zum Schluss sind, sehr hart ist, hart wie festes Eis. Nicht wie Staub oder Matsche. Dafür waren sie dies sein. Eine andere Bohrart, die ich im Allgemeinen als Bohrer bezeichne, ist das SD-Square-Instrument. Das ist ein dedizierter Bohrer, der eben konzipiert war, um Proben zu nehmen von der Oberfläche oder eben auch aus der Tiefe von der Bohrung und diese Proben dann in Öfchen zu füttern, um mit den erwähnten Evolved Gas Analyzer Messungen zu machen. Diesen Bohrer haben wir aktiviert, aber erst gegen Ende der Sequenz, um auszuschließen, womöglich den Lander durch den Versuch zu bohren, zum Umkippen bringen und dann alles verloren ist.
Das heißt, in dem Moment muss man eigentlich zu vielen kritischen Entscheidungen fällen. Welches Instrument darf jetzt schon loslegen und welches nicht?
Man muss schnell die Entscheidungen treffen. Man hat ja nicht viel Zeit, sonst verliert man die Energie und man muss die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen und die Risiken abwägen. Speziell eben, wenn es darum geht, Mechanismen zu aktivieren, die womöglich den Lander zum Umkippen bringen oder irgendeine Veränderung der stabilen Situation auf diesem Landeplatz bewirken könnten.
Aber es kamen alle Instrumente zum Einsatz?
Es kamen alle Instrumente letztlich zum Einsatz. Wir sind immer mutiger geworden. Wir haben am Anfang die eben nur zum Einsatz gebracht, die keinen Mechanismus benötigen. Also Kameras, die Massen-Spektrometer im Sniffing-Mode, Magnetometer, akustische Sensoren. Haben dann den Mupus-Pen, diesen Penetrator, der sich einhemmern sollte, ausgefahren. Und haben dann auch mit dem Bohrer versucht, eine Probe zu gewinnen und in ein Öffchen zu setzen.
Und? Das Öffchen hat auch geheizt.
Der Bohrer hat im Prinzip funktioniert. Also von Ausfahren, Einfahren, Öffchendrehen hat funktioniert. Das Öffchen hat auch geheizt. Auch das Instrument hat gemessen. Das Gaschromatogramm, das wir gewonnen haben, daraus sind wir noch daran zu analysieren. Aber es ist kein sehr deutliches, kein sehr starkes Signal. Es kann daran liegen, dass wir nur sehr wenig oder überhaupt keine Probe gewonnen haben und das Öffchen platzieren konnten. Es kann daran liegen, dass die Probe, die wir gewonnen haben, eine nicht volatile war, also so ein Sandkorn, das dann bei 250 Grad wenig ausgasst. Da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen Zeit, das näher zu verstehen. Es ist auf jeden Fall kein starkes, deutliches Gaschromatogramm gewonnen worden. Die Mechanismen an sich haben allerdings funktioniert. Das wissen wir von den Housekeeping-Daten. Was nicht hundertprozentig sicher ist, ist, ob der Bohrer wirklich den Boden berührt hat oder ob er überhaupt keine Chance hatte, eine Probe zu nehmen.
Das ist ja dann sozusagen das Drama, was jetzt in der Folge dann passierte durch dieses Zweiben. Also es ist ja zweimal aufgekommen und am dritten Mal liegen geblieben.
Naja, der ist also gegen den Kraterrand geklatscht und dann noch mal gehobst und ist dann liegen sitzen, wie immer stehen geblieben an einem, das weiß man noch nicht, leider Gottes sehr dunklen Ort, also irgendwo in einer Höhle, wenn Sie so wollen, oder hinter den schattigen Wänden, die sieht man auch, auf den Bildern der Panoramakamera, der Schieberkamera, diese Wände rundherum. Und wir hatten eben nur ungefähr eine Stunde 20 Licht auf dem Solargenerator pro Kometentag. Das ist sehr, sehr wenig, eben nicht ausreichend, um den Lander warmzuhalten und um den Betrieb fortzuführen, nachdem die Batterien leer waren. Daher ist der Lander in eine Art Winterschlaf verfallen, ist wahrscheinlich auch sehr stark abgekühlt, aber Komet und Lander bewegen sich immer näher an die Sonne. Wir hoffen in naher Zukunft, in der Ioni, dass dann der Input der Sonne reicht, zumindest zunächst mal in diesen eineinhalb Stunden, die immer beleuchtet ist, den Lander wieder zu aktivieren und wieder Signale vom Lander zu bekommen. Bis jetzt ist es nicht gelungen, aber wir nähern uns jeden Tag.
Das ist schon mal probiert worden, aber bisher gab es noch keine Antwort.
Das ist zuallererst im März mal für eine Periode probiert worden. Da wussten wir, dass wir noch weit von der Sonne weg sind. Aber ich meine, man wird es probieren. Man möchte ja auf keinen Fall die Daten verlieren. Man muss es einmal probiert haben. Wir probieren es zurzeit, jetzt im April nochmal. Aber auch das ist jetzt noch so ein Probieren. Probieren kostet in dem Fall nicht sehr viel, außer dass man eben die Empfänger am Orbiter einschaltet. Mai, Juni haben wir dann eine realistische Chance. Wenn es Mai, Juni nicht ist, Juli wird es nochmal besser. Der Sonnennächste Punkt ist im August.
Aber ist nicht die Annäherung an die Sonne auch ein Problem? Weil der Komet ja immer mehr anfängt auszugasen, sich insgesamt erhitzt. Sind die Ausgasungen des Kometen an sich ein Problem?
Also das Ausgasen ist weniger ein Problem. Staub kann ein Problem sein, wenn nämlich der Staub zurückfällt und sich auf dem Solargenerator ablagert. Dann ist der negative Effekt. Dann sind wir zwar näher an der Sonne, würden mehr Sonnenlicht bekommen, aber der Solargenerator, die Solarzellen, sind bedeckt durch Staub und wir bekommen wieder weniger. Im Moment sieht es so aus, auch an diesem Landeplatz, wo wir sind, das sieht man von den Bildern, dass da wenig Staubablagerungen sind. Aber natürlich, das könnte ein Problem darstellen. Staub, Gas weniger. Gas stellt eher ein Problem für den Orbiter dar, in die Orbit zu gehen, die nahe, beim Lambda sind nahe an der Oberfläche sind, um besser kommunizieren zu können und vor allem, um das Radarinstrument nochmal zu wiederholen, um da weitere Scans durch den Kometenkern zu bekommen. Das wird sehr schwierig.
Aber das hat auch schon stattgefunden und schon während des gesamten Landevorgangs?
Einen solchen Scan haben wir durchgeführt. Das ist ja eines der Experimente, die können Mechanismus erfolgen, erfordern ein Radarinstrument. Da haben wir einen Scan. Wir haben das Instrument dann nochmal zum Einsatz gebracht, um die Position des Landes durch das Ranging zu bestimmen oder einzugrenzen. Aber ein Scan ist für ein dreidimensionales Modell ein bisschen zu wenig. Die Kollegen würden sich freuen, wenn sie die Gelegenheit bekämen, noch einen oder idealerweise noch mehrere solches Scans durchzuführen.
Auf der Suche nach dem Lander, also man weiß ja, wie genau ist der Landeplatz jetzt schon eingegrenzt worden?
Der Bereich durch diese Konsertdaten ist nicht sehr groß. Das sind einige 10 Meter mal einige 10 Meter. Das ist also nicht so eine ganz große Ungenauigkeit. Und die Kollegen, die verantwortlich sind für die Bilder der Orbiterkamera, der Osiriskamera, die suchen jetzt nach dem Lander, um den wirklich auf einem Bild zu identifizieren. Es gibt auch Kandidaten, die vielleicht dieser Lander sein könnte. Allerdings die besten Aufnahmen, die wir jetzt haben nach der Landung. Aus Dezember wurden aus ungefähr 20 Kilometer Höhe gewonnen, zum Zeitpunkt der richtigen Beleuchtung. 20 Kilometer Höhe heißt, dass der Lander so 2x3, 3x3 Pixel groß ist. Und das ist nicht ganz leicht, einen Lander, der noch dazu irgendwie getan ist, weil er Schattenwurf, das sieht ja nicht genau wie ein Lander aus, den drauf zu erkennen. Und darum ist das so schwierig. Und darum passiert es auch, dass man falsche Lander findet. Oder man hat irgendetwas gefunden, das sieht aus wie ein Lander, aber es stellt sich dann heraus, das ist eben doch kein Lander.
Kann denn Rosetta noch näher ran?
Das war auch mal vorgesehen, für Juli noch mal näher ranzugehen. Wird jetzt wieder diskutiert, das ist immer eine Abwägung. Das Risiko für die Raumsonde durch das Ausgasen, durch den Staub, durch ihre Führung der Sternsensoren, durch zu viele Staubteilchen, die Sterne vortäuschen.
Das ist jetzt schon einmal passiert.
Ja, da ist ganz konkret ein Fehler mal passiert. Da ist Rosetta in einen, nennt man, Safe Mode gegangen. Also es hat sich so abgestellt und in einen Mode gebracht, einfach nur wieder Kommandos von der Erde zu bekommen. Hilfe rette mich. Das war deshalb, weil zu viele falsche Sterne in dem Sternensensor waren. Der kann ganz gut umgehen mit bis zu 2000 falschen Sternen und nur ganz wenige wirklichen. Da erkennt er immer noch die Sternbilder, was ich bemerkenswert finde. Aber in dem Fall waren ihm dann so 8.000 oder 10.000 falsche Sterne Staubteilchen und dann wusste er nicht mehr, wo er ist und ist in diesen Safe Mode gegangen.
Das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, dass jetzt durch die erweiterte Aktivität des Komenten so eine Situation gar nicht mehr herzustellen ist, dass man sich noch näher ranwagen kann.
Ja, das sind eben zwei. Das eine ist näher ranwagen für Kommunikation. Da bin ich zuversichtlich, das können wir. Da können wir auch 100 km vom Kern weg sein und trotzdem kommunizieren. Das andere ist näher ranzugehen als die Bilder, die wir schon aus 20 km haben. Und ich bezweifle, dass wir das jetzt um Perihelium herum machen werden. Vielleicht in einer viel späteren Phase von Rosetta, wenn wir wieder weiter weg sind vom Kometen Ende 2015 oder wenn die Mission verlängert wird 2016, ist ja auch dann noch interessant und wichtig, um den Kontext besser zu verstehen.
Wann wird der sonnennächste Punkt erreicht?
Das ist am 13.
August 2015.
Aber wie gesagt, auch später dann, selbst wenn der Lander dann nicht mehr aktiviert werden kann, wenn man dann noch Bilder gewinnen, die den Lander deutlicher zeigen an seinem Landepunkt, würde das helfen, die Daten zu interpretieren, den Kontext besser zu verstehen und auch diese Radar-Daten noch besser zu kalibrieren, wenn man genau weiß, wo das Pendant zum Radar-Instrument am Orbiter platziert war.
Ja, ich muss mal ein bisschen Kontext schaffen. Wir haben heute den 28. Mai, wo wir jetzt hier gerade sprechen. Das heißt, es sind jetzt im Prinzip noch so drei Monate.
Wir hatten den 28. April.
Äh, richtig.
Und wir hoffen, dass er bis zum 28. Mai vielleicht schon den Lander aktiviert hat.
Ich hatte ja auch schon Hoffnung, dass wir hier mit dem Termin vielleicht schon ersten Vollzug melden können. Aber okay, also ich verstehe, es ist nicht einfach. Das Ding ist optisch fast kaum auszumachen. Aus den Daten der Landung selber, die man jetzt von viele gewonnen hat, was konnte man denn da überhaupt heranziehen, um diese Einschränkung auf diesen 7-Meter-Bereich zu machen?
Zum einen haben wir Bilder. Und zwar nicht nur die Bilder von den Lander-Kameras, sondern auch der Orbiter mit, wie der Osiris, aber auch der Navigationskamera hat den Lander gesehen auf einigen der Bildern, sowohl im Anflug, als auch dann beim Abprallen. Und da konnte man die Trajektorie relativ gut rekonstruieren. Zum anderen haben wir die bereits erwähnten Arranging-Daten von dem Radar-Instrument, wo man relativ gut triangulieren kann und die jetzige Position bestimmen. Das sind auch Daten, die wir haben. Wir haben aber noch andere Daten herangezogen, Housekeeping-Daten, zum Beispiel vom Landebein, um dieses Abprallen und die Geschwindigkeit besser zu rekonstruieren. Wir haben sehr nützliche Daten von Romab, vom Magnetometer, die uns die Lage des Landes im Raum zeigen. Wir wissen also zwar von Romab nicht, wo an der Oberfläche ist, aber wo die Z-Achse ist, also wie der ausgerichtet ist. Das wissen wir ziemlich gut. Das ist ein Kompass, wenn Sie so wollen.
Wie ist er denn ausgerichtet?
Das müsste ich jetzt zeigen auf einem Bild. Ist ein bisschen schräg. Was heißt schräg? Man weiß nicht, wo das wirklich lokale Terrain ist. Wenn Sie das mitteln über die Ente, dann ist er schräg. Das heißt nicht, dass er nicht Boden unter den drei Füßen hat, weil da eben gerade so eine Welle oder ein Surface-Terrain ist, wo er dann doch zur Oberfläche relativ gerade sitzt. Aber er scheint eben etwas schräg in einem Loch oder hinter Wänden zu sitzen.
Wie weiß man denn, ob die Füße alle Kontakt haben?
Das akustische Experiment deutet an, dass zumindest zeitweise alle drei Füße den Boden berühren. Ich sage zeitweise, das heißt, er kann so ein bisschen wackeln, so ein paar Zentimeter. Aber es gibt Anzeichen, dass die Füße tatsächlich am Boden oder in der Nähe des Bodens sind.
Das war wirklich eine bemerkenswerte Landung, auch so in der Wahrnehmung, köstlich die Begleitung von dem bekannten Webcomic XKCD, der sich ja dazu herausgefordert gefühlt hat, nicht nur einen lustigen Comic über diese Mission zu machen, sondern das Ganze auch noch in Echtzeit zu begleiten. Wirklich eine fantastische Live-Berichterstattung, wie es sie, glaube ich, so von einem Raumfahrtprojekt auch noch nie gegeben hat. Das war wirklich, ich habe da auch zu den Hunderttausenden wahrscheinlich gehört, die da regelmäßig auf Reload geklickt haben, um zu gucken, was jetzt sozusagen die nächste Interpretation der Situation ist. Überhaupt hat man gemerkt, dass so die Spannung, die durch die Begleitung, durch diese Echtzeit-Begleitung der Landung, die erzeugt wurde, doch enorm war. Hat man das irgendwie mitbekommen?
Naja, das mediale Interesse haben wir natürlich mitbekommen. Und das war auch erstaunlich ein bisschen überraschend. Also es war mir schon klar, dass das interessant wird, auch für die Weltöffentlichkeit. Aber diese weltweite Response, diese Begeisterung für ein Raumfahrtprojekt, das hat mich auch ein bisschen überrascht. Die Echtzeitberichterstattung war natürlich spannend für die Menschen und ich glaube auch deshalb spannend, weil eben nicht alles geklappt hat. Wenn wir ganz brav gelandet wären und verankert und dann Massenspektren und Magnetogramme gewonnen hätten, dann wäre das vielleicht weniger nachvollziehbar gewesen, als wenn man da landet und dann prahlt man ab. Dann weiß man nicht genau, wo man ist. Dann sucht man den Lander und hofft, dass er am nächsten Morgen wieder aufwacht. Dann überlegt man sich, ob man den Bohrer bedienen möchte oder nicht. Das sind Entscheidungen, wo jeder mit Hausverstand sich hineindenken kann und eine Meinung dazu hat oder die Entscheidungskriterium nachvollziehen kann. Es ist dann auch immer wieder spannend, was ist jetzt drei Stunden später passiert und wie lange hält die Batterie? Wacht er wieder auf und welche Daten haben wir gewonnen? Es ist eben doch ein Bild gekommen, das Panoramabild, nicht gleich am ersten Tag, sondern am zweiten Tag. Wir haben da unfreiwillig eine ganz gute Story geboten. Das ist auch ein Grund, warum zumindest über die ganze Woche, wo eben die Aktivitäten waren, das mediale Medieninteresse geblieben ist und die Leute das sehr eng verfolgt haben und auch mitgefiebert und gezittert haben.
Es ist eigentlich sehr schön zu sehen, dass das so eine Beteiligung findet, obwohl es ja eigentlich so ein menschenbefreites Projekt ist. Da landet halt kein Mensch auf einem Kometen, was natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Wirkung für sich erzeugen würde, sondern halt nur so ein Roboter, der sich eigentlich noch nicht mal selber bewegen kann. Ich finde das ist eigentlich sehr positiv.
Ja, was heißt nur, wenn ein Mensch, wenn ein Astronaut landet, dann landet ja auch nicht derjenige, der am Fernseher sitzt und das verfolgt. Insofern ist der Unterschied vielleicht gar nicht so groß. Da ist eine Raumsonde, die landet, die wird von einem Kontrollraum gesteuert. Man sieht das Gleiche wie die Experten. Das ist ein Unterschied zu einem Astronauten, der das natürlich ganz anders erlebt, wenn er selbst dort ist. Vielleicht kann man sich damit noch mehr identifizieren mit dem Projekt, mit dem Erlebnis, mit der Exploration, dem Herausfinden, wie sieht es aus auf einem Kometen, was kann man dort lernen, als wenn man beobachtet, wie irgendein auswählt Astronaut am Mond ist. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es unbedingt so einen großen Unterschied machen muss.
Aber irgendein Unterschied hat es auf jeden Fall gemacht. Ich denke, das ist auch wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen eine Summe der besseren Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten über das Internet. Lisa hat ja auch wirklich sehr viel daran gearbeitet, möglichst schnell diese Informationen rauszubekommen, also die Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten, das zu verfolgen, auch wenn man ja eigentlich so gar nichts machen konnte, außer zu gucken. Die waren aber auf jeden Fall sehr ausgeprägt und sehr gut. Also ich hab das alles sehr positiv empfunden. Und ich glaube, das hat auch dann alles so ein bisschen darauf hingearbeitet, dass so ein hoher Grad an Beteiligung und Begeisterung sich breit gemacht hat. Was haben wir denn jetzt? Ich meine, muss ich auch sagen, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sind viele Daten gewonnen worden. Die wissenschaftliche Arbeit fängt im Prinzip jetzt erst an. Wir können uns jetzt hier auch über vieles noch gar nicht unterhalten, weil die Daten erst mal angeschaut werden müssen. Ein paar kleine Erkenntnisse hat es schon gegeben. Was weiß man denn jetzt sicher über Kometen, was man vorher nicht wusste?
Es hat viele Erkenntnisse gegeben. Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr auf die Erkenntnisse eingehen, die man vom Orbiter gewonnen hat. Das sind viele und es wurde auch diskutiert, dass das Wasserstoffverhältnis ganz anders ist als in den Erdozeanen. Und natürlich unser Beginn des Verständnisses, wie so ein Komet aussieht, wie die Aktivität ist, wo gast es aus, wo kommt der Staub heraus, wie sieht die Oberfläche aus?
Er sieht ja nicht aus wie in Asteroiden. Der Versuch der Antwort auf die Frage, kann so ein Komet das Wasser auf die Erde gebracht haben?
Genau, das war die Frage, woher kommt das Wasser in den Erdozeanen? Kommt es von Kometen? Kommt es von einer gewissen Art von Asteroiden? Kommt es aus dem Erdinneren? Und man hat lange Zeit überlegt, dass ein Großteil davon über Kometen auf die Erde kommt. Da gab es auch Indizien in dieser Richtung. Jetzt hat man das Wasserstoff-zu-Teuterium-Verhältnis auf den Tschurjumow gemessen oder in der Koma. Das ist ganz anders als im Erdozean. Also zumindest diese Art von Kometen, die waren nicht ausschlaggebend, vielleicht in gewisser Weise beteiligt, aber nicht ausschlaggebend für das Wasser in unseren Erdozeanen. Noch mal ein bisschen zu den Lander-Daten. Wie Sie richtig gesagt haben, die Daten werden im Moment analysiert. Aber wir haben natürlich Messungen durchgeführt. Wir haben organische Komponenten von der Oberfläche mit den Massenspektrometern messen können. Wir haben Erkenntnisse, dass das Material sehr hart ist. Also die Idee, dass das so ganz fluffig ist, wie Regolith in niedriger Gravitation oder Schnee. Das ist anders, das ist irgendwie gesintertes, festes Material. Das haben wir herausgefunden. Wir können aus den Kamerabildern und den Strukturen einiges ablesen, was man vom Orbiter nicht kann, weil wir eben die Auflösung im Subzentimeterbereich haben, sind das Granulen, das sind nicht unbedingt feine Staubteilchen. Einiges sieht aus, als wäre es Fels. Ich sage nicht, es ist Fels, aber es sieht aus wie Fels mit Kliffs drinnen. Das sind die Daten, die wir gewonnen haben, die Radar-Daten, die akustischen Daten, die elektrischen Daten, die dann das ganze Bild vervollständigen. Solche wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse nach einer Raumfahrtmission gehen im Allgemeinen in zwei Stufen. Die eine Stufe ist wirklich Beschreiben. Also ich sage, ich habe dieses und jenes Molekül auf den Kometen entdeckt. Das ist schon mal interessant. Das kann man innerhalb von Monaten oder vielleicht von einem Jahr, das sind auch die Publikationen, die man jetzt gerade in der Vorbereitung hat oder die Punkte, die demnächst publiziert werden oder bereits wurden. Der nächste Schritt ist es dann, das einzubecken in unsere Modelle vom Verständnis, wie ist das Sonnensystem entstanden, wie ist das Leben auf der Erde entstanden. Und wenn ich weiß, diese und jene Moleküle, diese und jene vielleicht auch Aminosäure, gibt es auf dem Kometen. Was könnte das bewirken, wenn es auf eine frühe Erde trifft? Welcher Chemismus läuft dort ab? Das wird viele, viele Jahre dauern und einige Promotionsarbeiten bewirken, dass man die bloße beschreibende Erkenntnis, dessen das gibt es auf dem Kometen, einbettet in ein, wenn solche Moleküle auf eine frühe Erde treffen, welcher Chemismus läuft ab, der dann letztlich zu Aminosäuren, RNA, DNA und Leben führt. Das wird länger dauern.
Aber gibt es denn jetzt eigentlich neue Planungen für Kometenlandungen oder ist das Thema jetzt erst mal durch?
Das Thema ist keineswegs durch. Es ist alles in Begeistert. Da freuen sich natürlich jetzt auch mal über die Daten. Und das werden ja Rosetta gewinnt nach wie vor Daten. Es wird immer spannender. Je näher wir an die Sonne rankommen, je aktiver der Komet wird. Aber natürlich gibt es Pläne für zukünftige Missionen. Ganz konkret zumindest in Amerika auf Naser-Seite, wo man im Rahmen der Discovery Proposals, also das ist eine Klasse von Missionen in Amerika bei der NASA, wieder Vorschläge eingereicht hat, für Missionen zu Kometen, um die näher zu untersuchen. Und der nächste ganz große Schritt, den man andenkt, wahrscheinlich auch nur in Zusammenarbeit mit der NASA, ist dann doch nicht das Labor zum Kometen zu bringen, sondern Proben von dem Kometen zurück zur Erde zu bringen. Was entsprechend anspruchsvoller ist, als nur hinzufliegen, wenn man eben nicht nur die Proben gewinnen muss, sondern dann auch die wieder zurückbringen muss zur Erde. Dann hat man alle Möglichkeiten der Labors auf der Erde für die Untersuchung, kann das naturgemäß viel genauer machen und kann diese Proben auch lagern, dass in 10, 20 Jahren neue Analysemethoden auf der Erde entwickelt werden und die dann anwenden, ähnlich wie das bei den Mondproben gemacht wurde, wo man ja nach wie vor neue Erkenntnisse gewinnt aus den Mondgesteinen, einfach weil die Analysegeräte auf der Erde besser werden und man die Proben, die in den 60ern und 70ern zur Erde gebracht worden sind, jetzt besser untersuchen kann.
Aber landen muss man ja trotzdem noch.
Natürlich, wenn man Proben nehmen will, muss man landen oder zumindest in irgendeiner Weise so ein Touch and Go machen, ein bisschen wie das die Hayabusa-Sonde, die Japanische bei dem Asteroiden Itokawa gemacht hat. Mal kurz runtergehen, Proben nehmen und sich dann aus dem Staub machen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Und was hat sich jetzt von den Philae-Mechanismen schon, also kann man schon sagen, ob sich irgendwas so bewährt hat, dass man sagen würde, vermutlich würde man das wieder genauso machen? Gibt es irgendwas, wo man sagen würde, vermutlich würde man das eher nicht so machen? Also diese Schrauben zum Beispiel?
Ja, die haben sehr gut funktioniert. Also wenn ich wieder mal irgendwie ein Lander bauen müsste, wo man eine sehr genaue Abstoßgeschwindigkeit braucht.
Ach so die Schrauben, ja die Abstoßschrauben. Die Schrauben, die sich in den Boden reinschrauben, die sind wahrscheinlich auf zu hartes Material getroffen.
Ja, das war jetzt nicht unbedingt die Schuld der Schrauben, sondern es war unerwartet, dass wir so ganz hartes, wie eben festes Eis, Material getroffen haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das nochmal so bauen würde. Den Dämpfungsmechanismus in dem Landerbein war sicherlich auch eine gute Idee. Es hat sehr vieles funktioniert. Vom Konzept der, von der tatsächlichen Realisierung wird der nächste Lander natürlich andere Bauteile, andere Computer. Das ist jetzt Technologie der 90er, wenn es um Elektronik geht, das wird man nicht nachbauen wollen. Auch die Instrumente sind zwar State of the Art, aber man könnte sie halt da wohl etwas genauer bauen oder noch mehr miniaturisieren. Da sind einfach 20 Jahre ins Land gezogen, das ist klar.
Ja, ich denke gerade Sensorik hat da auch große Vorteile gemacht.
Also man wird die nicht die Identischen wieder fliegen, das wird man nicht machen.
Aber hat denn, es war ja jetzt im Prinzip ja so ein bisschen so ein Unfall, dass man eben dreimal aufgesetzt ist, aber das hat ja dann auch Vorteile gehabt für bestimmte Messungen. Ich glaube, ein paar Wissenschaftler haben sich gefreut.
Also ein paar Wissenschaftler haben sich natürlich gefreut. Für das Magnetometer war das sehr gut. Das war sehr wichtig, dieser Überflug über die Oberfläche. Und die hatten geplant, ihre besten Daten zu gewinnen, knapp vor der Landung. Und die haben dann natürlich gewonnen, dass wir in relativ niedriger Höhe über die Oberfläche dahin geflogen sind und die ideal messen konnten. Für das Magnetometer war das wie gewünscht. Andere Instrumente, die Tirolis, die Kamera, die nach unten blickt, hat auch sehr gut, also mehr, als sie eigentlich erwarten durften, gemessen. Andere Instrumente konnten jetzt nicht so viel messen, gerade die, die auf die Proben angewiesen waren. Es konnten diese Evolved Gas Analyzer nicht zu ihrem vollen Potential Daten gewinnen. Die haben schöne Messungen, aber nicht alles, was möglich gewesen wäre dazu, hätte man die Long-Term Science gebraucht und Wochen und Monate und mehr und mehr Proben mit unterschiedlicher Temperatur zu messen. Ein interessanter Fall ist, dass der Punkt, wo wir jetzt Lampen gelandet sind, ist ja ein Bereich, wo wir es wahrscheinlich nicht riskiert hätten zu Lampen, weil das irgendwo so zwischen den, ich sag Felsen, es sind keine Felsen zwischen, Eisfelsen, was immer es ist, zu Lampen, was interessant ist, was ziemlich sicher pristines Material ist und in gewisser Weise spannender ist, als die mehr so staub- und regolith-bedeckten flacheren Gegenden. Und das ist etwas, wo wir Glück gehabt haben, was wir sonst bei der nominalen Landung wohl nicht riskiert hätten. Also es gibt Vor- und Nachteile. Vorteile, ja, wir haben noch einen Überflug gemacht, wir haben mehr als einen Landeplatz untersucht. Der große Nachteil oder das Pech, das wir hatten, in dem vielen Glück, das wir hatten, ist, dass eben der endgültige Landeplatz halt sehr, sehr schlecht beleuchtet ist und wir daher nicht sofort mit der Long-Term Science beginnen konnten und nur diese 2,5-3 Tage Messzeit zunächst hatten.
Aber ich denke, es ist doch sehr viel mehr erreicht worden, als man sich eigentlich am Anfang nur hätte erhoffen können. Allein, dass man überhaupt erst mal bis zu diesem Kometen kommt, ihn monatelang umkreist und dann auch noch was drauf absetzt, ist ja schon...
Ja, viele Leute haben uns sehr verrückt oder zumindest toll Köln betrachtet. Ich hab's gesagt, wir hatten natürlich auch viel Glück, dass das dann letztlich doch so gut funktioniert hat. Die ganze Kette vom Start bis zu der langen Großphase, bis zur Hibernation, bis zu Rosetta-Raumsonde, die ja wirklich exzellent funktioniert hat und auch den Einschuss in den Orbit, die Kartierung, die Landeplatzselektion, Einschuss in den Delivery Orbit, Separation, all das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Die Landung selbst hat immerhin auch funktioniert, wenn auch nicht ganz so wie geplant. Also diese ganze Kette, wenn da irgendetwas dazwischen fehlgeschlagen wäre, wäre die Mission verloren gewesen.
Und wenn jetzt auf einmal doch wieder genug Sonnenlicht kommt und das Ding erwacht und den Akku voll lädt und man hat auf einmal dann doch noch alles gemacht und man müsste jetzt eigentlich nur noch woanders hinkommen, kann er sich denn noch bewegen?
Naja, er kann sich bewegen, er kann den Landerkörper auf dem Dreibein drehen. Wir haben den auch ein bisschen gedreht in der Hoffnung, uns in die Sonne besser zu drehen. Man könnte auch das Landerbein nochmal ausfahren und so ein Ort Hopping machen. Daran kann man denken. Ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt nochmal die Chance kriegen, ein paar Wochen dort zu messen, wird es nicht das erste sein, dass wir versuchen, da wegzuhüpfen und womöglich dann erst am Kopf zu landen und nicht mehr kommunizieren zu können. Also wir werden eher versuchen, uns nicht zu bewegen, sondern die Position und die dann vorhandene Energie, wenn wir dann die Batterie aufladen können, nutzen, um einfach Messungen zu machen, die wir noch nicht machen konnten. Oder andere wiederholen unter etwas anderen Bedingungen. Einfach noch mal Kamerabilder unter einer anderen Tageszeit, anderer Beleuchtung, Temperaturmessungen, natürlich interessant, bei einer anderen Distanz zur Sonne noch mal zu wiederholen. Die Massenspektren, was gast aus, welche neuen organischen Moleküle kann man da entdecken, wenn der Komet wärmer wird. Es gäbe sehr viel, was man machen könnte, wenn einander genug Energie hätte.
Ich glaube aber, der Gedanke eines hüpfenden Roboters auf einem Kometen beflügelt dann auch noch mal die Fantasie.
War ja ganz, ganz früh mal vorgesehen. Der Urvater des Landes, Helmut Rosenbauer, Max-Planck-Direktor, der hat das damals angedacht, dass man dieses Landebein auch zum Hüpfen verwenden könnte. Und wir haben das nur deshalb aus dem Missions-Design letztlich herausgenommen, weil wir dachten, wenn wir mal gut gelandet sind und verankert werden, werden wir den Teufel tun, das Risiko einzugehen, dann noch mal weg zu hüpfen. Aber rein prinzipiell ist die Idee nicht so absurd.
Hüpfen auf fernen Kometen. Stefan Ulamets, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu viele. Ich wünsche der Mission noch viel Glück.
Ja, danke sehr.
Ich hoffe, die Sonne scheint noch mal an die richtige Stelle und wir finden das Ding noch mal. Das wäre wirklich sehr zu hoffen. Wie lange kann die Mission insgesamt maximal noch dauern?
Also Rosetta selbst ist nominal. Jetzt definiert bis Ende 2015. Das ist aber einfach ein programmatischer Endpunkt. Ich gehe davon aus, die Mission wird verlängert, tief ins Jahr 2016 hinein. Irgendwann wird uns das Hydrazin ausgehen. Dann kommt es natürlich zu einem Ende der Mission, wenn man nicht mehr diese kleinen Bahnmanöver machen kann, die notwendig sind, um den Kometen zu manövrieren. Dann kann man sich überlegen, ob man ein langweiliges Ende möchte und einfach wegdriften oder ein spektakuläres. Und irgendwie die ganze Sonde auf dem Kometen abzusetzen. Beide Optionen werden im Moment diskutiert.
Ja, könnte man sich ja viele nochmal interessante Art und Weise nähern. Gut, ich sage danke nochmal. Vielen Dank, vielen Dank hier auch fürs Zuhören und wiederzuschalten zu Raumzeit. Es wird weitere Ausgaben geben in diesem Jahr. So viel kann ich schon mal sagen. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.